i'm half white half filipino which means
my dad was in the military
a lot of soldiers were fighting for this
country my dad was dating
[Music]
i'm not knocking what my mom had to do
to get to america that was her hustle
she did what she had to do she could
have hooked up with a filipino and had a
kid in the philippines
you know how much a comedian makes in
the philippines
a chicken and flip-flops
that is las vegas in his latest netflix
special
he's one of the most successful
comedians on the circuit today
but now he's giving people a look behind
the laughs
in his new memoir called mixed plate i
talked with joe about the inspiration
for his book
i think it was just time you know uh one
thing i i wanted to always
stress out to people is uh you know you
see you see certain people get
successful i guess and uh and
you know you you you you judge fast
without learning
their backstory and i think if you read
someone's story you'll appreciate more
uh about how they made it in in their
careers so
that's what this is you know a lot of
people think oh it's just netflix
that put them on the map and it's like
no there's a lot of things i had to go
through a lot of ops
a lot of obstacles i had to conquer and
jump over it to get to where i'm at
and this book gave me the opportunity to
say that well joe talks a lot about his
mixed race he says being white and
filipino
created challenges breaking into comedy
it's crazy that that we talk about
systemic racism now and
it was just normalized for me were you
know coming up through the uh
you know the ranks it's something that i
just thought was normal
and i i didn't know it was you know
something that was actually bad that was
happening i don't know how to explain it
but it's just like when you hear
all the time that people aren't gonna
get what you're saying or
oh you can't do these rooms on the
weekend but you could do these
theme shows uh during the week and you
know
you know there was like certain rooms
for us called asian invasion or slanted
comedy and it's like
you're like wow is this really happening
well writing the book was very
therapeutic joe says
and he also broke some exciting news
with us about his next big project
steven spielberg and dan lynn over at
right back
films and steven spielberg over at
amblin we're getting ready to shoot a
movie
uh with me so let's go you guys uh
look out for it is it the life story of
joe coy
it's it's called easter sunday it's a
movie that i came up with and uh pitched
it to him and it's it's
it's beautiful it's going to talk about
my culture it's good
comedy it's chaos it's everything that
happens in one day easter sunday so get
ready
well joe said he can't wait to get back
on stage and of course we can't wait for
him to get
back here in the studio and visit us
again and tell you when joe comes in the
studio
he takes over the show well the newscast
is gone
it's all joe and he he tries to do the
news the weather the traffic
and it's it's just all comedy and it's
so fun to have him so we can't wait to
have him back oh yeah absolutely well we
could have used that today
we could barely function with hector
seemed like he got a scoop there sherry
about the movie though well
the movie too yeah and he didn't say
when it's coming out when they're
shooting or anything but just the fact
that spielberg's interested he's picking
this up
uh so i think that's going to be awesome
what a great career
bump for him i mean that takes him into
a whole new realm right movies now
absolutely yeah wow easter sunday i
think he said it was cool yeah
anytime you're working with steven
spielberg as a producer wherever the
case may be that's a that's a good thing
so way to go mr coy
a very funny man of fellow las vegas and
he's doing pretty well for himself
shares a good interview